russia is one of the largest countries
in the world and it's now become one of
the most important countries when it
comes to bitcoin why is that russia's
central bank has been attacking bitcoin
by saying that they are proposing a ban
they want nobody trading bitcoin they
want nobody trading cryptocurrency they
want nobody mining bitcoin or other
cryptocurrencies either the central bank
is taking a abrasive view of these
digital assets but the finance ministry
and now russian president vladimir putin
are actually saying wait a second we
shouldn't ban this we should simply
regulate it here's why that's important
ultimately russia is wanting to get
involved in bitcoin and cryptocurrencies
president putin has said that russia has
some advantages in bitcoin mining
specifically he has been talking about
the idea that there are areas where
there's a surplus in energy here's a
direct quote he said we also have
certain competitive advantages here
especially in the so-called mining i
mean the surplus of electricity and
well-trained personnel available in this
country now the surplus of electricity
is in a number of regions in russia it
usually comes from their hydroelectric
plants that they have and also they have
soviet area industrial facilities have
been shut down but are still wired to
actually create tons and tons of
electricity there's racks of mining
devices like you can see here in norwich
russia i didn't say that right but you
get the point and ultimately what you
can see is that russia one of the
largest countries in the world if they
begin to actually embrace this if they
say we're gonna create a regulatory
framework we're gonna allow people to
buy and sell bitcoin we're gonna
actually encourage money maybe the state
even gets into actually mining bitcoin
if russia wants to buy bitcoin and put
it on its balance sheet that would be a
shot heard around the world bitcoin's
price would absolutely skyrocket if
russia started to embrace bitcoin there
are also things that are a little bit
more complex that they could do they
could actually start to price oil or gas
in bitcoin rather than in dollars or
other currencies i don't know if that's
necessarily the best geopolitical move
because it would be an abrasive attack
right against the us dollar in the
united states and so ultimately what we
are watching is a global game theory
play out here this geopolitical
competition where china has gone ahead
and actually kicked out all of the
people who are mining bitcoin they've
gone after everyone who's trying to buy
and sell bitcoin they've also kicked out
a lot of the companies that are trying
to support the assets as well and then
we see a place like el salvador el
salvador is obviously embracing it
they're plugging their country right
into the bitcoin network they bought
bitcoin they built software products for
bitcoin they've built atm networks for
bitcoin and they've even gone ahead and
said that they're going to create
bitcoin city and they are going to
launch bitcoin backed bonds all of that
is because el salvador is now left onto
the center of the global stage using
bitcoin as a way to encourage people to
understand they see the future they want
to be innovative and they want to be at
the forefront the united states we're
somewhere in between we have some
politicians and a number of companies
that are saying look this is good for
business bitcoin is american technology
it stands for everything we stand for
and we should embrace this and we should
drive it forward it can be a signal and
a driver of economic prosperity moving
forward but ultimately there are still
many politicians and lots of people both
commentators and entrepreneurs who don't
see the value who think that it's stupid
who completely want the industry to go
away and so we're not necessarily
net bullish as a country we're also not
net negative as a country either we have
been the biggest beneficiary of china's
decision to kick all those miners out
more than 10 percent of the global hash
rate now resides in uh texas and about
30 percent globally resides within the
united states borders and so ultimately
the united states has become one of the
world's largest miners but ultimately
russia russia has a decision to make do
they follow the central bank plan and
actually ban this stuff both from
trading and a mining perspective or will
vladimir putin and the finance ministry
end up going ahead and creating that
regulatory framework and say we're going
to get into the game russia gets in the
game it will kick off that global game
theory and there will be more countries
that continue to follow el salvador was
the first domino will russia be the
second nobody knows yet but if we see
them go hard into this space i think
it'll beg a lot of questions both from
an international kind of politics
standpoint and also that game theory
playing out what happens to financial
markets what happens to other asset
classes and what does this mean for the
world
the ball is now in russia's court and
we're all paying attention waiting to
see what they're going to do what do you
think john yeah i think putin runs
russia central bank said we want to ban
this i think it's not going to be banned
i think it's gonna be regulated in the
sense that he wants he's also creating
that public narrative um and basically
you don't know what he's saying behind
closed doors russia is the third largest
miner in the world for bitcoin so that's
a very very big deal if they decide to
go ahead and ban that or they go ahead
and put the pedal of the metal in the
scent and
regulate it and get involved in the
mining themselves with all the plants
that they have and the access to the
surplus of the electricity um but yeah
that's a big deal and also look if they
start pricing oil in bitcoin that's
gonna be an insane thing for bitcoin
that's gonna rapidly increase the price
of bitcoin um and it's very well
possible right if they decided to
if they decided to invade ukraine um the
u.s backs with sanctions they back
ukraine and impose sanctions on russia
russia can go ahead and remove the
dollar as their reserve currency and go
ahead and implement bitcoin as
what what oil is being priced in right
and that would be a very very big move
um i don't expect that to happen but
it's definitely a possibility and on the
table
joe yeah i think uh people have been
predicting kind of some theory of this
for a long period of time right with the
kind of a global hash war and uh if
russia was to get involved in that
they're already the third largest but if
they really started to put government
resources behind it and really go all in
on this they could quickly uh kind of
capture a lot of this market and as you
said the us has been a big beneficiary
of the china ban but ultimately like we
haven't been pro-regulation on all this
stuff right we haven't been the
government hasn't really put all their
resources and their power behind it so i
think if russia was to do that you saw a
couple other big countries do something
similar the u.s would have no choice but
to do something similar also right like
you don't want to fall behind where it's
much more difficult to get five percent
10 20 50 and lose that lead that you
currently have so i think the us will
respond if russia does something like
this and ultimately like that's the kind
of stuff that's going to drive the price
up right if you get this war between uh
different countries kind of competing on
the security of network all it does is
make it all stronger and it be and it
becomes a much uh much more
institutional great asset it becomes
much more secure more people are
demanding this asset and ultimately the
price will rise because of the the
constrained and fixed supply
john when you think about this you said
that uh putin runs russia right he kind
of has an iron fist uh that he's able to
rule with and i agree with that um when
you think about uh kind of bitcoin
playing into this do you think at all
about like this ukraine russia uh thing
that everyone's talking about do you
think bitcoin plays at all or those two
different topics that uh won't
necessarily overlap i think it's a tool
that can be used um especially to get if
they want to against the united states
in the sense of their oil and um
everything that goes along with that but
i don't think that it will be um i think
it's on the table and you really don't
know um like we don't even know what
russia's plan is why they're putting a
bunch of troops near the border all that
um but it's a possibility it's on the
table i think uh hopefully it doesn't
but if they do i think that will
basically create a um a financial war
between the united states and russia
that they're going to be competing for
bitcoin if russia decides to go fully
and do it the u.s is either going to be
lagging behind and not get involved at
all bannon in the united states which i
also don't think is a real possibility
but could happen um or they go ahead and
they say all right let's compete for
mining let's see who can get more
electricity and more people involved in
the cryptocurrency space in their
country and i think the united states
would win in that situation if you had
to uh
look 10 years out
who do you think would own most of this
uh the hash rate globally u.s u.s you
think yeah i i don't think that it's
actually a good thing for the united
states to have more than 50 percent of
the hash rate either right it's just
like it's not good you're trying to
distribute it yeah you wanted to be as
decentralized and distributed as
possible uh but i think that that on a
per country basis the united states will
have the most right it's the it's
regulated fifty percent right it could
be if yeah if they have 30
right and the rest is spread globally
nobody has more than let's say 33
percent uh i think that uh if i had to
pick one country that's going to have 33
percent then it'd be the united states
yeah one is they already have a big leap
two is uh lots of oil and gas you know
in places like texas etc the third is a
lot of people forget how important
regulatory climate is so the ability to
know what the rules are to clearly have
a kind of transparency around that and
then also to have the predictability
that they're not going to change every
time somebody wakes up and says i want
this i want this i want this um and so
you can't build a business in those
environments where you have to do it and
they kind of clearly but do you think
the u.s is that place right now i think
the united states
i think the united states is the most
clear cut when it comes to mining in
terms of the rules that are in place
today are likely to be the rules that
are in place a decade from now uh
although the united states has plenty of
challenges right and we've talked about
them ad nauseam on this show uh i think
that it has the least amount of
corruption it also has the least amount
of non-democratic process meaning that
you can't just uh you know have uh the
politicians come in and say you can't do
this anymore yeah like wait hold on a
second there's voting right there
there's obviously china balance
overnight right like literally there was
one region yeah and they basically you
know crushed the whole thing so like
there are some similarities other places
in the world where i'm not saying that
the united states is perfect but what
i'm saying is that if you're going to go
build a business it's true in every
industry right what is the place that
has the greatest regulatory kind of
clarity right in in all these different
places in the united states right and
it's not like from a is it a security is
it not a security right which a lot of
people encrypted talk about i'm talking
about the fact of like you know what the
taxation is you're not worried about
somebody from the government showing up
and being like
we want all the bitcoin right
give us your miners right you don't have
to worry about that stuff in the united
states and so uh i think that ultimately
ends up being um you know if there's
anywhere in the world there's the the
safety and uh kind of stuff here